major construction projects the new
digital economy or greener technologies
just some other things Europe could do
with a 350 billion euros of investments
the Sun promised by the Commission
President jean-claude Juncker was a
subject of debate in the chamber I have
a vision of school children in tests
alone icky walking into a brand new
classroom I have a vision of a French
commuter being able to charge his
electric car along the motorway in the
same way we fill up on patrol today of
these three hundred fifteen billion
euros only 16 it would be supplied by
the EU and 25 by the european investment
bank the bank arm of the union according
to Younker these 21 billion years would
then be used to raise the rest of the
money through private banks a magic
trick according to some but good news
according to others every year more than
6 million children die from preventable
diseases before their fifth birthday
while the rightful place of a child is
at school there are still more than
hundred sixty million children engaged
in child labour this year is a 25th
anniversary of the UN convention of the
rights of child I'm eps have used the
occasion to urge the EU to respond
effectively shackelford wawa venosa
conferred whitewash history avoir statue
jelly dick over zuska present to later
on for non Padua and statues Riddick
Sookie Ocean tuvalu effect is on phone
in Belgium UNICEF mark the 25th
anniversary of children's rights in the
presence of Queen Mathilde the aim was
to give the floor to today's younger
generation and raise awareness of the
big task ahead
member states and the Parliament are
locking horns over the 2015 EU budget
emmy peas refused to endorse the next
budget if outstanding bills from
previous years are not settled back
payments from 2010 total 30 billion
euros we need to solve it once and for
all and then we can start from a clean
table and that's the only way we can
have credibility in the eyes of the
citizens next round 28th of November the
European Commission is sent to propose a
new draft budget if no agreement is
reached by the first of January 2015 the
EU will have to pay its bills on a
monthly item-by-item basis the wrong
signal to be sending out to citizens